- Finally, we have a pick from
Drew's Little Yellow Book.
- Oh!
- Yes, that's right.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- It is my personal curation
that I work with everyone
on the show with,
because I think that if I
was a professional curator
I would be happy.
- Yeah.
- So we refresh it every single week,
we're very thoughtful about it,
we do all the picks ourselves,
and this week I'm excited because,
I did a social post about this,
and it just brings me to nostalgia city.
I'd just seen "Spider-Man" and,
has anyone seen "Spider-Man" here?
- I hear it's so great.
(audience clapping)
- It is so good and it is
about the power of three.
- Mm.
- Which takes me back
to the best time a girl could ever have
and that was being one of three
with the "Charlie's Angels."
So Flower Beauty made this
Flower Beauty X Charlie's Angels Pallet,
which is now available exclusively
with our beauty partners at CVS
and you can get it on flowerbeauty.com
and it looks like a DVD,
and there's all these treats with it,
and the colors are like Angels Eyes,
Starfish, which is what Tom
Green called me in the movie,
I liked it so much I married him.
(laughing)
Speaking of there's The Chad, Dylan,
Good Morning Angels, Independent Women.
- Hey.
- Because I will never forget
being in the trailer and we heard the demo
from Destiny's Child, "Come In."
- I just heard that song the other day
and I was like, Drew that's you!
You get a shout out,
does that get-
- Lucy Liu.
- Yeah.
- With my girl, Drew,
Cameron D., and Destiny,
"Charlie's Angels" come on.
And they were three women.
- Yes, they were.
- I mean, being in your early 20s
and trying to produce a
"Charlie's Angels" movie
and hear Destiny's Child songs,
"Coming In," it was just,
it was the best time-
(audience clapping)
- That's so amazing.
- In the world.
- Was it?
- It really was.
It was, you know, we spent five years
making two of those movies,
they each took two years to make.
We trained, we toured the
world, we became best friends.
You know it was us three girls
and there is something about
that, trinity, that trio,
that triangle, that's
unshakeable and yeah,
so this feels very meaningful
for me to be a part of and put
out in the world right now.
So if you wanna get in touch-
(audience clapping)
With your inner little superhero,
go to CVS or the Flower Beauty website,
and get your Flower Beauty
X Charlie's Angels Palette.
It's time for a pick from
The Little Yellow Book
which is my personal guide
to things that I really
wanna share with you,
I can't contain it.
Okay, today it's an incredible list
created by The Strategist.
They have 28 gifts under $50
from Hispanic-and Latinx-Owned Brands.
There's Noche Clara, a
cactus soap by Nopalera.
An exfoliating bar with active charcoal,
oh, I'm there for that.
And of course the versatile Beautyblender,
created by incredible makeup
artist, Rea Ann Silva,
she's been on the show,
it's now recyclable.
Get the full list on our
website from, The Strategist,
one of my faves.
(audience clapping)
I just wanna
thank Machine Gun, again,
for also being a man
who reveals his feelings
and a gentleman who is putting
something so fantastic out in the world.
He's such a trendsetter,
and changing what men
do with their fashion,
and flair, and expression.
So his LAQR company, UN/DN LAQR,
as we heard about, 'cause
he's looking to have a name
that is less than
perfect, we are all UN/DN,
it's very sexy too.
And this is just incredible, this product.
I applaud him for putting
it out into the world.
He has a giant platform, people
are following what he does.
It's exciting when people
take this artistic license
and do things that include everybody
and I'm so excited to make sure to promote
this fantastic new brand that
he has put out into the world.
As we got into much and
many discussions at the core
also of what we wanted
to present to everybody
is this wonderful
company that he's started
and I'm just so excited for this launch.
He's such a trendsetter
and just gives the license
for us all to play and
I just could not applaud
this launch more.
So get your UN/DN LAQR and play.
(upbeat music)